show time
a month after an election no one here
thinks he lost
they're calling it a victory rally they
cheated and they rigged our presidential
election
but we will still win it we will still
win it
the focus also on a key runoff vote for
georgia's two seats in the senate
the president here to issue a rallying
cry for the republican candidates
and himself you got to get out and vote
let them
steal georgia again you'll never be able
to look yourself in the mirror
we have to hold the line and you have
two of the greatest people
on earth you have to hold the line make
sure that
you and everyone else know that you have
to register to vote before this monday
donald trump is back in campaign mode
but he has a dilemma
he's still crying foul about the
election and raising concerns about the
security of the vote
in next month's senate runoff but donald
trump
needs his supporters to cast their
ballot because if they don't
and the democrats win then the balance
of power in washington
shifts fundamentally in president-elect
joe biden's favor
impossible to conceive if like everyone
here
you think president trump's the winner
he is not going to let up
he is our chief executive he is our
commander-in-chief
he is going to defend the republic joe
biden did not win
and he will not win the man is he's a
puppet man
hey sit down though mommy's gonna take
our picture down the road in the city
center
it's christmas cheer not election fever
on display
little time for president trump and his
claims of fraud
i feel like he's just kind of acting
like my toddler where he didn't get his
way and now he's upset about it
and i feel like that's just ruining any
chance of him for me voting for him in
the future elections
i really don't support him coming i
don't want him here
he just needs to give it up
but there's no sign of his supporters
tiring
a last dance perhaps before reality
dawns
debra haynes valdosta georgia